hey everybody it's me Noel and I'm here
on a beautiful spring day to show you a
POI trick for the worldwide POI
challenge this is a beginner trick and
it looks like
this all right so basically what
happened was that there's all this wind
because it's springtime but here I am
doing the trick with one po instead of
the wrap that goes on the bottom it
actually reaches all the way around and
wraps back onto the same arm that's
swinging it I'm going to do it the other
direction here where I reach over the
opposite arm and it wraps back onto the
same
arm and with twoo it can be really
really cool like to do both stalls at
the same time which looks like
this all right again my name is Noel y
I'm here with the worldwide for you
challenge and a big shout out to Justin
hindy who taught me this trick many
years ago